today we are off to Colorado where
there's one of the biggest coronavirus
testing experiments there is a
husband-and-wife team Lou Reese and Mei
Mei who happen to be executives at a
biotech company which is trying to test
every single person in San Miguel County
in Colorado which includes Telluride the
company is also trying to develop a
vaccine for the virus so let's head out
and talk to Lou and Mamie your company
makes vaccines for animals and and for
humans you've been working on a vaccine
for Alzheimer's and Parkinson's yeah so
I mean if it were any other time Ashley
you and I would be talking right now
about how we're gonna move forward with
our registration trials for Alzheimer's
in the States
but instead today we're all of all
all-hands-on-deck on on kovat you're in
Telluride it's part of San Miguel County
and you have a test a blood test that
you're looking to test all 8,000 people
in San Miguel County is that that the
basics yeah testing is such a big issue
if you look at the countries that have
kind of dealt with this the best is
testing is one of the core principles
and what it does is it brings knowledge
a lot of the tests that we read about in
the news right now it's it's like the
nasal swab and and it's mostly looking
at do you have kovat 19 right now in
this moment but you have a blood test
which shows not only if you have it now
but also if you've you've already had it
and developed antibodies against it so
antibody tests are what we use to screen
blood banks for us is the same type of
technology so people come in they get
their blood drawn those all get
collected and then those samples those
specimens get flown to labs to then
process
and then the lab reports the results
back to the county the idea is how do
you screen large swaths of populations
quickly find and trace down the ones
that are potentially infected to
quarantine them and then also find the
ones that have developed antibodies some
level immunity and get them back out
that's the trick you're in this part of
Colorado that's super spread out I think
there's like two and a half like public
health officials for these 8,000 people
and so it's tricky right because I know
they were looking for volunteers I mean
you have to teach people how to do a
blood draw and and so I mean as it
played out pretty smoothly has it been
even harder than you thought or one of
the reasons where we did it here in San
Diego County was because like there's
not even a hospital in San Miguel County
but the medical community here and the
EMTs knew what they were doing with the
blood draw component also we did it here
because it's a visionary community and I
think that the community saw what the
opportunity was to get the data and it
was hilarious how awesome and supportive
they've been you guys are doing this for
free and paying for all these tests and
then I should add is voluntary it's not
like people have to do this but so do we
know when like what's your goal for how
long this will take and how many people
you'll get I think they've done a really
good job in terms of getting people
through so I think it's almost averaging
like a thousand a day and so we should
have results sometime next week and then
we do it all over again because because
you want to sort of test once and then
test a couple weeks later yeah cuz you
know it's zero conversion which is what
happens when your body decides to
develop antibodies doesn't happen
overnight it takes some sometime after
your body's exposed to the virus to be
able to develop you know antibodies so
we want to be able to catch that that's
why we want to wait you know at least 14
days between to make sure if someone has
been infected that they Sarah converted
and we can identify it and then so you
guys have a couple of things going on I
mean so not only are you doing this you
you also back when when SARS was a huge
concern you done vaccine work around
that and so it seems like you were
pretty quickly able to spin up some
tests around a possible vaccine here
for the novel coronavirus so you know
we've tested a number of different
constructs we're actually looking at
them right now they look pretty
promising there in animals and our hope
is to get them into humans early summer
are we any closer to sort of knowing
when we'll get the data from the animal
test still ongoing and then Lu not to
put you on the spot but I mean I know
you were saying Li if the animal test
came back if the data came back good you
would you would sort of think about
doing using the vaccine at that point
right I'm totally down as long as it
doesn't damage I get FD a path or
anything like that right now we got a
little bit of interim data and I would
say that we are one step closer to
having the like the one or two that we'd
like to pull the trigger on for human
trials and I'm like first in line
I'm before there's a line and so you
look at this data from the animal trials
and then if it looks safe you can kind
of progress immediately in the human
trial yeah and then it's really about
how the FDA wants to deal with these
trials right but these are emergency
times unprecedented so all we know is
that we're gonna try to get the the best
vaccine into the humans right now make
sure it's safe and one of the benefits
of our platform and our company is that
we have scaled up we have a commercially
validated platform
I think scaling up and delivering is
going to be just as difficult as finding
a really efficacious vaccine that can be
you know distributed to the masses it's
hard to keep track of all the different
vaccines and approaches that would be
being taken right now but like how
optimistic should people be because I
just don't give people false hope or I
just want to set expectations in the
right spot yeah yes so the example that
I give people is that remember a few
years ago reading about pigs that were
dying in China by like the thousands and
millions and stuff there was a mutation
to foot-and-mouth disease and within a
month of finding out then being charged
with solving that we made a hundred
million brand new vaccines - a brand new
strain that worked and solved the
problem so the answer is
these things can go really really fast a
lot of things have to work out together
but I think there's gonna be a lot of
push to solve it yeah I mean there's a
ton of different vaccines going on I
mean there's you know over 20 efforts
that are just listed right now and
they're probably more efforts that we
don't even know about the good news is
that there are lots of people working on
it and when you have lots of people
working on it that means more shots on
goal which means that you should feel
good and hopeful that something will
come out this is like a challenge for
Humanity I don't care if it's us I don't
care if it's you know another company
with a different technology is one to
work and to be able to scale up and for
us to get back to a new normal where you
know we can still think about going out
having 4th of July parties having
concerts and stuff so I'm just thinking
about like what wouldn't you get all the
data from San Miguel County is that
something you would like sort of analyze
yourself is that something that goes up
on a website that everybody can see it's
definitely all anonymized um the people
who are positive are notified directly
by the Met Center so there will be
quarantined or like isolation based on
who's infected and then hopefully the
rest of the community can feel safer
about coming out one thing that is weird
actually that's strange about doing this
it's one thing to deploy it in distant
places even if you know those places
really well it's another one you're
deploying it like right there and
everybody's like you know in it it's
it's really amazing well thank you guys
and it was really appreciate your time
god thanks Ashley we should actually
talk later
you